en apparence les héros les plus connus
de notre pop culture n'ont pas les mêmes
origines
ils ne sont pas devenus des héros de la
même manière si certains sont plus
humains donc plus proche de nous
d'autres ont acquis un pouvoir
[Musique]
et certains sont même nés avec mais ces
différences sont en réalité
superficielles parce qu'il n'existerait
qu'une seule et unique manière de
devenir un héros je suis romain et vous
êtes sur mille idées de culture générale
à en croire ce livre le héros aux mille
et un visages de joseph campbell toutes
les cultures sans exception partage à
travers leurs différents mythes le même
archétype du héros je vais comme l
appellent ça le monolithe la raison
profonde en est que tous les récits
seraient liés entre eux dans
l'imaginaire humain en tant que
manifestation d'un besoin universel
d'expliquer les réalités sociales
cosmologique et spirituelle ce que cette
hypothèse explique c'est que l' aventure
du héros serait en fait une allégorie de
la manière dont tout homme peut parvenir
à la maturité spirituelle
je vais illustrer cette idée tout au
long de la vidéo avec plusieurs héros
hollywoodien batman spiderman superman
et néo de matrix comme joseph comme
belle aime beaucoup la psychanalyse il
montre avec ces outils d'analysé que les
lieux les personnages et les objets des
mythes
ils ont la même fonction que dans le
rêve ils travestissent l'évolution de
l'âme le long du destin individuel
le grand enseignement de cette
démystification de la mythologie c'est
que le héros et bien c'est chacun
d'entre nous
l' aventure du héros avec ses étapes
obligatoires
c'est aussi c'est surtout la nôtre
chacun peut devenir un héros
rien peut tout déclenché un geste
maladroit peut être le signe d'une
destinée parce que la théorie freudienne
des actes manqués révèle qu'il est
l'expression d'un désir inconscient très
profond dans spider-man par exemple la
piqûre d'araignée apparaît bien sûr
comme de la pure malchance mais ça n'est
bien évidemment pas un hasard si ça
tombe sur peter parker le destin le
choisit lui parce qu'il en a le
potentiel morale parce qu'il est déjà un
héros dans son coeur
mais l'appel de l'aventuré généralement
plus explicite le futur héros est en
quête de lui-même il se cherche ce qui
montre bien qu'il est au seuil d'une
transformation spirituelle son centre de
gravité a tiré vers une zone inconnue
symbolisé dans les récits mythologiques
comme un pays lointain une forêt un
royaume souterrain une île secrète mais
circonstances de l'appel ne sont jamais
anodines elles présentent des signes du
destin et des épreuves à venir
enfin le héros est parfois grossièrement
prédestiné comme hercule qui étrangle un
serpent dans son berceau où clark kent
enfants qui soulève une voiture
[Musique]
malgré le pouvoir d'attraction de ces
signes du destin son appel peut rester
sans réponse mais ce n'est généralement
qu'une hésitation durable jusqu'à la
révélation providentiel le héros n'est
pas seul dans son périple après avoir
accepté l'appel
il reçoit souvent une aide surnaturel de
la part d'une figure protectrice qui le
prépare à affronter l'adversité des
épreuves à venir et tu fasses do you
believe that may be strong au fast and
the woman morceau est le héros se méfie
du guide mais il le suit de manière
irrationnelle parce qu'il incarne l
influence bienveillante et protectrice
du destin cette figure et la plupart du
temps féminines comme la vierge dans les
légendes chrétienne
elle est plus rarement un personnage
masculin tel un un habitant des bois un
sorcier accès
elle est le guide qui fait franchir le
seuil d'un monde nouveau au héros en
devenir
le franchissement de ce seuil est une
annulation de soi une mort symbolique
nécessaires à la renaissance héroïque
c'est la phase préféré des récits
mythologiques
ils la font durer ils la décrivent en
détail les scénaristes de hollywood le
savent bien
c'est une étape fondamentale du parcours
du héros
[Musique]
et certains n'hésitent pas à lui donner
explicitement le sens initiatique
auxquelles elle renvoie
brive les épreuves du héros cela
corresponde bien évidemment à
l'initiation du profane dans les
sociétés secrètes de l'antiquité à nos
jours
le but c'est de transformer le candidat
pour en faire un homme nouveau régénéré
moralement pour joseph campbell les
récits mythologiques ne font que rendre
visibles toutes les constructions
symbolique de l'imagination qui sont
présentes dans la psyché de n'importe
quel adulte
ce rapprochement révèle la véritable
nature des épreuves du héros ce ne sont
pas des épreuves de force d'endurance ou
même de courage ce sont fondamentalement
des épreuves morales
le véritable voyage du héros est en
lui-même dans les profondeurs de son
esprit il ne pourra renaître qu'en
mettant à mort son ego
entamée par une mort intérieur les
épreuves initiatiques aboutissent à la
renaissance
le héros est un nouvel homme le succès
de son périple est souvent concrétisée
par la conquête de la femme tentatrice
qui symbolise en fait la conquête du
destin la figure féminine peut même être
la jauge de la progression du héros
plus fondamentalement la fin des
épreuves c'est à dire l'apothéose
signifie l'accession à un niveau
quasiment 10 20 elle est parfois
interprétée comme la recherche de
l'immortalité physique ou sur le plan
psychologique comme l'expression d'un
fantasme d'invincibilité de l'enfance
mais c'est faire fausse route pour
joseph campbell le véritable sens de
l'apothéose héroïque c'est que le corps
et la personnalité physique afférentes
cesse désormais d'entraver la vision
comme lorsque nez on réalise sa
connexion intime à la matrix
[Musique]
la libération intérieure du héros
s'accompagne d'un nouveau rapport au
cosmos il ne vit plus sur le seul plan
physique mais dans tous les corps et à
toutes les échelles du monde
[Musique]
le héros a découvert qu'il était lui
même l'objet sa propre quête il a
embrassé son destin est prêt pour
rentrer mais rentrée n'est pas si simple
que ça parce que des puissances
surnaturelles s'oppose au retour
ces puissances elles peuvent être un
gardien des dieux ou des démons qui
désapprouvent le désir du héros de
réintégrer le monde profane le retour
est alors en lui même comme une épreuve
de plus autre cas de figure
ce peut être la société qui jalouse de
l'éloignement du héros se charge de le
ramener au bercail et one knows where he
min
mais les problèmes ne s'arrêtent pas là
le héros qui réussit à rentrer est
confronté à l'imperméabilité des hommes
comment traduire son expérience pour
diffuser son message
comment enseigner ce qui a été déjà
correctement enseigner est
incorrectement assimiler des milliers de
fois on retrouve ce thème dans les films
modernes quand l'opinion publique ne
reconnaît plus la valeur du héros même
qu'elle en fait son bouc émissaire
que le héros et les hommes ne soient
plus sur la même longueur d'onde
explique la fonction mythologique du
vêtement celui du prêtre de l'artiste
par exemple qui sait à séparer
l'individu spécial du monde comme vivre
dans les deux mondes n'est pas chose
aisée c'est un art de m
que de passer de l'un à l'autre sans
confondre leurs principes
cette maîtrise est généralement
l'apanage de personnages particuliers
comme des sages des dieux travesti etc
et c'est là que se sépare les destin
héroïque et lé destin divin
le héros échoue généralement à devenir
le maître des demandes
c'est pourquoi il est nécessaire qu'un
nouveau héros émergent puis refasse à
son tour le même parcours un nouveau
héros est nécessaire lorsque des
monstres primitif ou des tyrans menace
la communauté des hommes
ainsi le héros est l'agent du cycle de
la vie il reproduit dans le monde
l'élan initial qui le mit en mousse
alors je trouve l'idée de joseph
campbell très intéressante et elle est
probablement juste il n'est pas étonnant
qu'on la retrouve dans les blockbusters
hollywoodiens
parce que le livre a beaucoup influencé
les scénaristes et puis le sorcier qui
racontait un mythe c'est un peu
l'ancêtre du scénariste
voici peut être pourquoi les films de
héros plestan c'est exceptionnel en
apparence le héros serait en réalité
universelle il est tout sommes sur le
chemin spirituel qui le mène à
l'acceptation de son destin a épousé le
mouvement de la vie et donc en assumer
pleinement
l'inévitable culpabilité en termes plus
simples devenir un héros se serait
atteindre une forme de maturité
stoïcienne en renonçant à ses fantasmes
et en se fondant dans l'ordre du monde
et chacun peut se libérer intérieurement
ainsi en suivant la voie du r si le
travail de joseph campbell et très
descriptif il comporte aussi un message
philosophique
selon lui les forces du monde moderne la
liberté démocratique
la méthode scientifique puis la
technique est bien ils ont vidé les
symboles mythologique de leur pouvoir
alors que ces symboles sont censés aider
l'individu à franchir ses horizons
spirituel il n'y est plus du tout
sensibles l'homme moderne reste donc
immature son âme est coupée en deux
entre la zone consciente et la zone
inconsciente elle ne communique pour
joseph campbell le héros est plus que
jamais nécessaire
si vous avez aimé la vidéo donnez lui un
pouce bleus et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la
suivante si vous voulez lire mon article
de blog
inspiré de la lecture de ce livre le
héros aux mille et un visages de joseph
campbell voir pour lire directement le
livre tous les liens sont dans la
description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser vos
commentaires et enfin si vous voulez
recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisée dans le format le
plus clair possible
vous pouvez vous abonner à la newsletter
en laissant votre adresse mail sur le
site
je suis romain et vous étiez sur mille
idées de culture générale n'oubliez pas
que vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour vous intéresser au
meilleur de la pensée
[Musique]